und jetzt das heute
journal willkommen zum heutejournal am
Ende eines Tages an dem ein neuer Krieg
ausgebrochen ist von dem wir noch nicht
wissen welche Folgen er insgesamt haben
wird nur dass sie gravierend sein werden
die palästinensische Hamas hat in den
frühen Morgenstunden eine regelrechte
Invasion gestartet einen terroristischen
Großangriff der in Israel amatische
Erinnerungen an den JOM kipppor Krieg
vor genau 50 Jahren weckt und wohl auch
wecken soll mit dem Überraschungsmoment
an einem jüdischen Feiertag und mit dem
Ausmaß der Attacken im Süden Israels vor
allem ziehen Hamas Terroristen mordend
und marodierend durch Dörfer und Städte
sie massakrieren und entführen
israelische Zivilisten und Soldaten und
sie schänden Leichen zugleich schießen
sie von Gaza aus tausende Raketen auf
ganz Israel Christiane Hoffmann
berichtet Frauen und Männer als Geiseln
in Social Media Videos der Hamas aus
ihren Häusern geholt von der Straße
gezerrt im Morgengrauen verschleppt
Geiseln sollen sie sein für die
radikalislamische Hamas vielleicht als
schutzschildde oder zum Austausch gegen
eigene Kämpfer dieser Tag bringt eine
neue Dimension im Nahostkonflikt der
Angriff hat Israel
überrascht am Morgen beginnt er die
Hamas schickt mehrere tausend Raketen
aus Gaza auf viele israelische Städte
auch nach Tel Aviv Israel wird am
Feiertag aus dem Schlaf gerissen nicht
alle Raketen können abgefangen werden es
gibt Einschläge tote wie hier in
Aschkelon um 6 Uhr morgens ist eine
Rakete hier am Haus eingeschlagen alles
brannte das Haus wurde zerstört es gab
eine massive Explosion
zeitgleich stürmen mehrere hundert
hamaskämpfer den Grenzzaun von Gaza nach
Israel und Filmen sich dabei kurz nach
der Grenze Karn sie einen Panzer zerren
einen mutmaßlich toten Soldaten heraus
den anderen entführen sie nach Gaza noch
nie gab es so einen koordinierten
massiven Angriff der Hamas die drohten
in einem
propagandavideo wir haben beschlossen
den israelischen Verbrechen mit Gottes
Hilfe ein Ende zu setzen damit der Feind
begreift dass die Zeit in der er Unheil
anrichten kann ohne zur Rechenschaft
gezogen zu werden vorbei ist die Miliz
dringt nach Israel ein es gibt Kämpfe
unter anderem in sterot im kiputbereri
und ofakim verschanzen sie sich mit
Geiseln durchkämmen anderswo die Straßen
am Abend ist klar es gibt in Israel
mindestens 250 Tote und mehr als 1400
verletzte die Regierung von dem Überfall
völlig überrascht und bloßgestellt
Bürger Israels wir befinden uns im Krieg
nicht in einer neuen Runde der Gewalt
sondern im Krieg so der
Ministerpräsident und droht dass der
Feind einen noch nie da gewwesenen Preis
zahlen werde die Armee beruft alle
Reservisten ein auch das gab es lange
nicht in Israel und startet
Gegenangriffe mit Truppen am Boden die
in knapp zwei Dutzend Orten gegen
Eindringlinge kämpfen und mit massiven
raketenschlägen auf Gaza auch hier Tote
und
Verletzte zuvor ließen sich die Kämpfer
in Gaza mit ihren Opfern feiern mit
Toten und mit ihren Geiseln sogar eine
alte Frau wurde vorgeführt eine
Eskalation des jahrzehntelangen
Konflikts die Gefahr eines
Flächenbrandes in Nahost war lange nicht
größer schalten wir nach telaviv zu
unserem Korrespondenten Michael
beberunge der heute übertag auch nahe
der massiv angegriffenen Grenzstadt der
war Michael wie ist jetzt in Israel
insgesamt die Lage am
Abend nach wie vor außerordentlich
angespannt die Kämpfe sind mit der
hereinbrechenden Nacht etwas
abgeflaut es ist aber nach wie vor so
dass in diesen vorgelagerten Siedlungen
auf ihres israelischenem Territorium vor
dem Gazastreifen gekämpft wird es gibt
Berichte aus von weiterhin
stattfindenden kämpfen ins derot es gibt
weit hin diese geiselnamen wo sich
Terroristen mit dutzenden israelischen
Zivilisten in Häusern verschanzt haben
und die große Aufgabe ist es jetzt für
die israelische Armee und die Polizei
dort eine möglichst unblutige Lösung
herbeizuführen aber nichts deutet darauf
dass das tatsächlich gelingen wird
außerdem gibt es ja in Israel auch eine
Diskussion darüber warum der herrm ein
solcher Überraschungseffekt gelingen
konnte also warum an der Grenze zu G so
viele Milizen Terroristen eindringen
konnten man darf nicht übersehen das ist
heute so etwas wie ein 9-1even Moment
für die Geschichte Israels so etwas wie
der Angriff auf das World Trade Center
2001 in Amerika einen so präzise
militärisch geplanten durchgeführten
Terrorangriff den hat sich glaube ich
hier schlicht niemand vorstellen können
mit so viel Toten mit solcher Wucht
durchgeführt und vielleicht weil man es
sich nicht vorstellen konnte hat man
nicht nach Anzeichen gesucht oder die
Anzeichen übersehen diese Frage ist
natürlich heute vielfach gestellt worden
aber niemand hat auch nur annähernd eine
Antwort darauf geben können im Moment
konzentriert sich alles darauf eine
geschlossene Antwort auf die Bedrohung
zu geben und das heißt konkret dass man
nicht nur die Bedrohungssituation die
ich gerade geschildert habe beseitigen
will sondern
ganz konkret ist die Rede von einer
Bodenoffensive
nach Gaza die würde außerordentlich
blutig werden und würde wahrscheinlich
insgesamt hier die Rahmenbedingung im
Nahen Osten völlig umschreiben mm es
trifft ein Land Israel das
innenpolitisch auch seit Monaten in
auorr ist das das macht die ganze Sache
ja noch
komplizierter im Moment führt es eher
dazu dass die reihen sich schließen
Reservisten die vorher aus Protest gegen
die Justizreform und die Kappung der
Gewaltenteilung ihren Dienst verweigert
haben haben sich zurückgemeldet zum
Dienst Piloten es gibt Angebote von der
Opposition eine Notstandsregierung zu
bilden allerdings unter der Bedingung
dass Netanyahu die extremistischen
religiösen Siedler aus der Regierung
wirft was daraus wird es noch nicht
abzusehen im Moment rauft sich Israel
zusammen um dieser Bedrohung zu begegnen
danke Michael erstmal für diese
Information live aus Tel Aviv
nicht nur die Israelis wurden vom Ausmaß
der Angriffe überrascht auch in Europa
und den USA ist man geschockt dass sich
der
israelischpalästinensische Konflikt seit
geraumer Zeit wieder verschärfte das war
zwar nicht zu übersehen und es gab auch
Warnungen vor einer neuen Eskalation
aber dass die Hamas vom Gazastreifen aus
der Art massiv auf israelisches
Territorium eindringt zu Land zu Wasser
und sogar aus der Luft das war zumindest
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht erwartet
worden der Angriff wird weithin
verurteilt natürlich auch vom deutschen
Bundeskanzler bundesaußenministerin
berburg trat am Nachmittag vor die
Kameras aber schon jetzt ist klar dieser
Tag ist eine zesur ein präsidenloser Akt
der Eskalation durch die
Hamas das Vorgehen der Hamas ist durch
nichts zu rechtfertigen
nichts rechtfertigt unterschiedslosen
Raketenbeschuss kommandoangriffe auf
friedliche
Zivilisten die brutale Entführung von
unschuldigen
Menschen me zu den internationalen
Reaktionen jetzt von unseren
Korrespondenten in Washington und Berlin
Theo Koll es gab heute auch bereits ein
Telefonat zwischen Bundespräsident
Steinmeier und dem israelischen
Staatspräsidenten ja der Bundespräsident
hat seine volle Solidarität erklärt und
ist damit ja stellvertreten für das
gesamte politische Berlin äh neben der
breiten Unterstützung für Israel hier
haben sich aber heute auch mehrere
politische Diskussionen entwickelt die
eine dreht sich um die deutschen
Hilfsgelder für die Palästinenser im
Haushalt des kommenden Jahres sind ja
rund 350 Millionen Euro vorgesehen als
Hilfe für die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde und sowohl der
Bundesfinanzminister als auch
Unionsvertreter stellen diese Zahlung
jetzt in Frage zumindest müsste jegliche
Verwendung für anti-israelische Zwecke
ausgeschlossen sein und die zweite
Diskussion dreht sich um die deutsche
und auch europäische Haltung zum Iran
der so Michael rot jedenfalls der
Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
die Hamas finanziere oder mitfinanziere
Vertreter der Union ging dann noch
weiter der Iran stecke hinter den
heutigen Angriffen und die Waffen der
Hamas kämen wahrscheinlich auch zu einem
großen Teil von dort es sei also Zeit
für eine entschieden härtere Gangart
gegen den Iran Zugeständnisse um ein
atomabkommen zu vereinbaren sein
jedenfalls der falsche Weg die
Außenministerin hat aber den Iran heute
nicht namentlich erwähnt sie sprach
abstrakter von anderen Akteuren in der
Region die sie davor gewarnt hat sich
der Auseinandersetzung anzuschließen es
bestehe die unkalkulierbare Gefahr einer
großen regionalen Eskalation soweit
heute Berlin darüber sprechen wir g
gleich auch noch schauen aber jetzt
erstmal nach Washington natürlich
spielen die USA in diesem Konflikt eine
eine ganz herausragende Rolle auch als
mächtiger Partner Israels Elma twiesen
in Washington wie reagiert man
dort ja US-Präsident Biden hat natürlich
mit Premierminister Netanyahu
telefoniert danach ist der V die Kameras
getreten hier in Washington und er hat
gesagt dass die US-Regierung felsenfest
und unerschütterlich die Sicherheit
Israels garantieren werde ich will mal
ein paar Worte zitieren die ihm wohl
besonders wichtig waren lassen Sie mich
das so klar sagen wie es nur geht dies
ist nicht der Moment für irgendeinen der
Feinde Israels diese Angriffe zum
eigenen Vorteil auszunutzen die Welt
schaut genau hin also hier geht's auch
darum eine Ausweitung zu verhindern es
wird jede Unterstützung für Israel geben
einerseits durch
aufklärungsinformationen durch die
amerikanische
Luftaufklärung andererseits auch Zugriff
möglicherweise auf amerikanische Waffen
und Munition die USA haben ein Depot in
Israel aus dem sind aber in den letzten
Monaten auch sehr viele
Artilleriegranaten an die Ukraine
weitergegeben worden und die große Frage
die hier natürlich alle umtreibt ist
nicht nur wie Israel sondern wie auch
die USA die US geheheimdienste von
diesem Angriff überrascht werden konnten
jetzt prüft man noch mal alle
Erkenntnisse der letzten Wochen um
sicher zustellen dass man nicht noch
einmal überrascht wird wenn denn dieser
Konflikt sich möglicherweise auch
ausweiten würde mm danke erstm für diese
Einschätzung nach Washington und
Berlin zu jenen die den Terror der Hamas
heute bejubeln die gibt es natürlich
auch gehört selbstverständlich der Iran
und auch die libanesische Hisbollah die
heutigen Angriffe seinen Zitat eine
Botschaft an alle in der arabischen und
muslimischen Welt die versuchten ihre
Beziehungen zu Israel zu normalisieren
heißt es von der Hisbollah das lässt
tief blicken es gibt in diesem Konflikt
ja eben noch eine andere Ebene als der
unmittelbare Konflikt zwischen Israelis
und Palästinensern dazu gleich noch ein
Gespräch davor skizziert guline atai
kurz die zentralen Akteure in dieser
Region im bewöffneten Kampf gegen Israel
seit
1977 die USA die EU und Ägypten
bezeichnen die Hammers als Terror
Organisation ihre Ideologie gründet sich
auf der
Muslimbruderschaft sie regiert den
Gazastreifen ohne demokratische
Legitimation in immer weiteren Runden
feuert sie Raketen auf Israel oder
schickt
selbstmordatt hamasführer Ismael hanie
trifft sich regelmäßig mit Hassan
nasradla dem Chef der mächtigen
Hisbollah Miliz im Libanon baut die
Hamas eine militärische Präsenz auf
ihr Verbündete die hisbolla sie ist eine
schiitische politische Partei und
zugleich eine bewaffnete Miliz im
Libanon gilt sie als ein Staat im Staate
gegründet aufgebaut finanziert und
trainiert mit Hilfe des Iran die
hisbolla verübte terroristische
Attentate kämpfte an der Seite von
syriens Machthaber Assad und führte
Kriege und Scharmützel gegen
Israel
Iran und Saudi-Arabien sind die
übergeordneten Akteure des
Konflikts Irans revolutionsgarten eine
Inspiration für die Hamas aus Teran
kommt logistische und finanzielle Hilfe
Irans oberster Führer hamene erhofft
seit jeher das baldige Ende Israels die
heutige hamasoperation solle diesen
Kollaps
herbeiführen wer mit Israel kooperiere
setze auf ein totes Pferd sagt Führer
chamene damit richtet er sich vor allem
gegen ihn den saudischen Kronprinzen
Mohammad bin Salman angetrieben von den
USA verfolgt bin Salman eine Annäherung
und Normalisierung der Beziehungen mit
Israel ein Abkommen bezeichnete bin
Salman vor kurzem als immer näher
rückende
Option für Iran hboll und Hamas eine
Option die es unbedingt zu verhindern
gilt größeren Blick wollen wir jetzt mit
Guido Steinberg von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik noch mal werfen
als bekannt für seine Expertise für die
Konflikte im Nahen Osten guten Abend
Herr Steinberg guten Abend Frau slamker
wir alle Fragen uns natürich an diesem
Tag warum dieser Terrorangriff dieser
Großangriff ausgerechnet heute jenseits
von dem symbolischen JOM kepur
symbolischen Jon kepur Datum ich denke
dass der Hintergrund ganz klar ist das
sind die Verhandlungen zwischen Saudi
Arabien Israel und den USA im
Hintergrund über einen Frieden das ist
das große Thema in der israelischen
unter
palästinensischen Politik der letzten
Wochen und Monate und ich denke dass da
ein Akteur der außen vor war nämlich die
Hamas ganz klar machen wollte hier wir
sind auch noch da wir haben Einfluss auf
die Ereignisse und ihr werdet diesen
Frieden nur nur unter unserem Widerstand
schließen das ist ja im Prinzip ein ein
zynisches Kalkül wir reißen einen Krieg
von Zaun damit andere Friedensbemühungen
torpediert werden kann das
gelingen ja das ich denke dass es da
durchaus die Möglichkeit gibt das hängt
jetzt sehr sehr stark davon ab wie
israel reagiert und wenn Israel
beispielsweise mit einer großen
Bodenoffensive reagiert dann wird die
saudi-arabische Regierung wiederum unter
den Druck der öffentlichen Meinung in
der arabischen Welt geraten und auch
unter den Druck der Gegner Irans
beispielsweise die eigene Position zu zu
revidieren also das ist in jedem Fall
das Kalkül der Hamas vielleicht auch das
Kalkül Irans wie sehen Sie denn vor
diesem Hintergrund die bisherigen
Reaktionen aus der arabischen Welt die
sind ganz ganz klar gespalten besonders
interessant waren die Reaktionen heute
aus Saudi-Arabien dort wird ja nichts
veröffentlicht was nicht die Zustimmung
des Königshauses hat und da waren die
Stimmen doch sehr sehr kritisch die
Hamas wurde auch als terroristischer
Akteur bezeichnet das zeigt ganz ganz
deut dass da ein Bruch durch die Region
geht Iran Irak Syrien Libanon da waren
natürlich die Akteure auf der Seite der
Hamas wurde ja aus Israel offenbar eher
befürchtet dass die Hisbollah aus dem
Norden eine eine größere Aktion planen
könnte wie sieht's da im Moment aus ja
es war tatsächlich so in israelischen
Sicherheitskreisen wird bereits seit
letztem Jahr eine solche Möglichkeit
diskutiert es war immer wieder die Rede
von einem Szenario das sehr dem gleich
dass wir jetzt an der Südgrenze gesehen
haben nämlich dass Spezialkräfte der
Hisbollah die sehr viel stärker sind als
die der Hamas auf israelisches
Territorium über Tunnel beispielsweise
vordringen Geiseln nehmen Menschen
Menschen töten diese Möglichkeit ist
auch noch nicht ausgeräumt es gibt
allerdings bisher noch keinerlei
Anzeichen dafür dass die hisbolla
wirklich bereit ist ein solches Risiko
einzugehen israel hat bereits mehrfach
mit einem großen Krieg im Libanon
gedroht wenn his Hisbollah in dieser
oder andere Art und Weise gegen Israel
vorgeht und wenn man über die Hisbollah
redet dann redet man sofort auch über
Iran Klammer auf Verbündeter oder sehr
freundschaftlich verbunden mit
Russland ja das ist richtig Iran ist
sicherlich ein Akteur im Hintergrund ich
gehe davon aus dass die Hamas dieser
Entscheidung zur Offensive heute äh
eigenständig gefällt hat aber es ist
ganz klar dass sie Iran Raketen liefert
es liefert nohau es hat auch
hamaskämpfer in der in der Vergangenheit
trainiert und Iran hat in den letzten
Monaten immer engere Beziehungen zu
Russland aufgebaut in gewisser Weise
gibt es da eine indirekte Beziehung nun
vom russland-ukraine Konflikt über den
Iran Richtung Hisbollah und auch in
Richtung hamasm das muss man auch
erstmal sacken lassen wenn man jetzt
noch mal direkt auf den Krieg heute der
nun heute dieser Form eskaliert ist
blickt bringt das ja die Israelis in
eine eine unglaubliche Dilemmasituation
sie müssten da eigentlich mit voller
Härte reagieren sie sind militärisch
auch überlegen aber mit diesen vielen
Geiseln die genommen wurden ist das ja
ein riesen Problem ja das ist jetzt eine
Wahl die niemand haben möchte es gibt
jetzt die Wahl zwischen einer großen
Bodenoffensive die wird wahrscheinlich
den Tod sehr sehr vieler Geiseln
bedeuten und natürlich auch den Tod
eigener
Soldaten und ein dem Eingeständnis einer
Niederlage und dann einer Geiselkrise
die wiederum Jahre dauern kann
vielleicht mit ganz ganz unangenehmen
Bildern und Ereignissen auch für die
israelische Öffentlichkeit und Politik
verbunden ist ich äh denke dass die
Zeichen von heute eher darauf hindeuten
dass die Regierung Netanyahu mit etwas
mehr Gewalt vorgehen wird sie wird sich
nicht sie wird sich nicht damit abfinden
können äh dass Sie hier eine Niederlage
erlitten hat und jetzt einen langen
Verhandlungsprozess beginnen muss sie
wird in irgendeiner Weise versuchen
gegenüber der Hamas Stärke zu zeigen und
auch gegenüber der eigenen Bevölkerung
Handlungsfähigkeit zu zeigen Herr
Steinberg danke ihn für diese Expertisen
und Analysen danke
Ihnen laufend aktuelle Informationen zum
Kriegsgeschehen aber natürlich auch
viele Hintergründe und Analysen zu den
Konflikten im Nahen Osten finden Sie bei
uns wie immer auch online auf ZDF
heute und jetzt geht es bei Dir weiter
Heinz zunächst mit dem Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten in Washington her
Bundespräsident Steinmeer hat sich nach
dem Treffen mit US-Präsident beiden
gestern Abend optimistisch gezeigt dass
die USA weiter Militärhilfen für die
Ukraine leisten werden steinmeierer
sagte in Washington beide beiden habe
ihm versichert auf die USA sei Verlass
man werde die Ukraine im Kampf für ihre
Freiheit und ihre Demokratie weiter
unterstützenal im Westen Afghanistans
hat es schwere Erdbeben gegeben viele
Menschen sind ums Leben gekommen die
afghanischen Behörden sprechen von 120
Toten und 1000 Verletzten in der
betroffenen Region sind viele Häuser
eingestürzt und so wird befürchtet dass
die Zahl der Opfer noch weiter steigen
wird eine Meldung vom Sport in der
Formel 1 hat Max Verstappen zum dritten
Mal in Folge den WM-Titel sicher
vorzeitig nach dem Sprintrennen heute in
Qatar Verstappen wurde Zweiter hinter
Oscar piastre und hat jetzt einen
uneinholbaren Punkte Vorsprung in der
Gesamtwertung mehr sportn gleich im
Aktuellen Sportstudio jetzt die
Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne Gewehr 11 14 22 23 32 42
Superzahl 0 und weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
jetzt noch die Wetteraussichten für
morgen im Nordosten sowie im Südwesten
länger sonnig sonst viele Wolken in der
Mitte anfangs auch etwas Regen 14° an
der Oder bis 26° am oberrein die
weiteren Aussichten im Nordosten anfangs
noch sehr nass und kühl im Südwesten
dagegen viel Sonne und am Mittwoch bis
28°
warm das war's von uns im heute journal
an diesem 7 Oktober wir melden uns
morgen abend wieder die nächste heute
Express gibt's gegen 0:40 Uhr
[Musik]
wiedersehen